こんにちは、はじめ社長とJU(UNJUN)
去年の冬かなー
俺は、彼。しょーちょーしゅーちんぐ部（早朝シューティング部）の
（JUNJUN）言えてないから
（はじめ）ちょちょちょ
一対一で、負けたんでしたっけ？
（JUNJUN）負けたよ
（はじめ）負けましたよね？
（JUNJUN）負けた
負けちゃったんで
今、約この体育館は約35℃
気温の、この真夏の中
僕はこの半年間、あれ以来運動を一個もしてません。
ラウンドワンでしたでしょ
あ！ラウンドワンでちょっとしました(白目)
ラウンドワンで一回しました(白目)
あと、今日は一睡もしてません
今日はこの極限の状態でこのバスケ部の
ね？
プロッ、プロバスケットボーラーの
やめてそれ！一番ダメそれ！
PDA候補のJUNJUN選手
やめてそれ
今回はねちょっとこの極限の状態なんですけど、
まあ、極限でしか出せないバスケットのプレイもあると思うんで
今日は！彼を！ボッコボコにしてヤり(たいと思います)
よろしくおねがいします-はい
ピュウ♪
ッチなにすんだよ
ッチなんだよぉ！
お前何すんだよ！
おめえ！！
ピュルルン♪
(俺イケメンだぁ。。。)
絶対勝つからな
ビュルルルン(JUNJUNはじめの手に挟まれた)
♪
実況者はじめ「はい！いよいよ始まりました！はじめしゃちょーVSJUNJUN
早朝シューティング部の試合です！
一対一で先に11点取った方が勝ち！
先行ははじめです。さあどう出る
ピュン♪
おっと！ボールを回した！よくあるかっこつけです
どう攻める！シュート！
ここは外れる！
様子見かはじめ！軽くシュートを打った！
次はJUNJUN選手の攻撃！シュート打った！
スリーポイント！入ったァァァァァァ(荒ぶる)
ちっくしょう！悔しい！はじめ選手先制点を取られた！
JUNJUN選手は後攻スリーポイントからの試合の動きが始まりました！
まだわかりません(必死)
さあはじめ選手どう動くか。先生は取られた。三点！ここから巻き返しできるか
スリーポイント打った！きまる！
ここははじめ選手決めて3対3！試合の流れは振り出しに戻ります！
綺麗なアーチまだはじめ選手シュート力は健在か(自画自賛)
ギリギリはいってガッツポーズを決めた!
さあ、JUNJUN選手の攻撃どう攻める！
踏み込む！戻る！踏み込む！
シュート！
センター上に近いがそこは外れる(満面の笑み)
はじめ選手の身長が目立ったか
はじめしゃちょーの攻撃です！
さあ！3対3どう攻める
ドリブル！からのシュート
ダサい(大声)
わあ！シュートですゴールには夢にも届きません。
さあ、JUNJUN選手どう攻めるか。ドリブルドリブル
踏み込むｓｄｓｊｋはっｊふぁｊｆ
真横からのジャンプシュート！
おっと！ここはきれいに決まった！
これ実は踏み込むと見せかけて一回戻ってからシュートを打っているるのでチェックにはとてもいきづらいシュートです
はじめ選手どうすることもできず点数決められる！
さあ！ここからどう巻き返すかはじめ選手
シュート！すぐ打った！
嗚呼。。。。。。。。
さあJUNJUN選手の攻撃二点差です。
ちょっと苦しいかはじめ選手
狙う！スリー！打った！
決まったァァァァァァ(嘆き)
まずいです。ご点差です。
はじめしゃちょーはもうやる気が無いと見せかけて
からのドリブルドリブルからの真裏からのシュート！
決まる！
ここは素晴らしいはじめしゃちょー
まさかのゴールの裏からのシュート！
食い倒れ気味？ですが昔の記憶がまだ残っているのか
しっかりと技は身についているようです
JUNJUN選手の攻撃！三点差！
さあ、守れるかはじめ
シュート！スリーポイント！
ここは外れる。さあ、はじめしゃちょーの攻撃です。
なんとか埋めたい三点差。同じくスリーシュート！
ここは決める。はじめ選手きせきとｓｈｊふぁ。。奇跡ではないですよ？実力ですよ？(重要)
さあ、JUNJUN選手のターン
どう攻めるか緑からのジャンプシュート！
おっと！これは！！外れる(笑顔)
惜しい
さあ、はじめ選手のターン打つか！スリーポイントここから打つのか
一気に点数差は広まるか、
どう攻めるかドリブル！ついた！ドリブル！ついた！
狙う狙う！ドリブル突っ込む！回ってからのジャンプシュート
決まった！
やったここはしっかり決めてくる
顔で一回フェイング入れてからの
突っ込むと見せかけての
ドリブルで後ろを振り向きざまからのフライングシュート
これは流石に止めれない。JUNJUN選手！
綺麗に決まりました。10点目でございます。
さあ、JUNJUN選手どう攻めるか
10点差が開いております。
負けずと突っ込む！
決まった！
レイアップシュート実はこれ深いドリブルを一気に二回叩いてから
右から切り込んでいくまではじめ選手ついていけません！
レイアップシュート綺麗に決まって10対10！
同点です
先に決めたほうが勝ち！はじめしゃちょー先攻どう出るか
おっと無理やり突っ込む！
ドリブルゥォォォォｗｗｗ
ばかやろい♡
ここで日頃の疲れが出たか運動してないかはじめ
さあ、JUNJUN選手の攻撃！
さあ攻めるか、ここで決まるか！
決まったアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアアア
よっしゃ！かったぞ！ウフォッ⤴ウフォッ⤴八つ(？)ナイス富田()
ハア、、運動しようかな＾＾
(はじめ選手お疲れ様でした。)
はい！というわけで今回のゲスト！JUNJUNさんでしたぁ！
バシッ！
おい！お前なんか言ったろ今～！
ナンナイサー(？沖縄)
(うわ♡はじめかっこいい♡)
(ホントイケメンなんだからっ！)
(うわぁ！流石だね♡////)